this is
star talk sports edition and
for this installment we're going to talk
about the physics
of baseball physics of bass you probably
don't often see those two words in the
same place
now i know a little bit about physics
but i don't know as much about the
physics of baseball
as my good friend bill nye
special guest today bill uh neil
greetings star talk sports edition and i
got my co-host gary o'reilly gary
hi neal not that you're chopped liver
sorry i had to introduce bill
no no no bill takes priority i'm good
with that
and where did you send chuck today did
you banish him somewhere no we haven't
banished chuck chuck
has uh found gainful employment oh wow
okay he's got a job he's not going to
play instead of being he's a comedian
he's got to tell jokes when he can
do his thing especially during coved
well bill not many people know that you
we may know you're a fan of baseball but
you've actually
like studied it on almost a saber-metric
level
and so oh not not safe oh
it's kind of smelled that way and so i
didn't want to do this show without your
expertise
just lacing everything that gary and i
talk about but then i realized
okay to do this right i mean i played
little league but
we need somebody who's actually in the
sport and if we couldn't get an mlb
person let me get the next best thing
i got a college baseball coach who also
happened to be my trainer dj price dj
welcome to star talk
hey what's up neil how you guys doing
welcome back to start talk this is not
your first time
second time here yes look he's fine
he's fine so you're coach where are you
a coach right now
uh barry university i'm an assistant
coach there assistant coach
in florida um north miami and they're
division two
division two yes division two and you
said like they've
and where did they rank in that in
recent years uh i mean last year before
the
uh the covet hit they were they were up
in the the top 15 in the country
and uh 9-0 they were undefeated they
were going through a pretty good time
and then everything hit
but uh they were leading the country in
most offensive categories which is a
big deal yeah okay very very cool well
glad to have you on this we're going to
tap you for
in case something in case bill says
something that doesn't
feel right we're going to get your
reaction to it okay it's not often i get
an opportunity to override bill
well no you're you're you're you're our
street view of what what bill guy says
because
bill's going to hand us some science and
bill lately i haven't caught up with you
lately
um you've got a new podcast science
rules great
title so what's the what's the format of
that one of my oldest uh
turns of phrase science rules uh so the
format is we have guests on
and we talk about science we had
jennifer dudenon just the other day
wait who's the world she wanted you say
we have guys uh me and corey
it is i corey s powell and i corey so
he's your co-author on a couple of books
yeah so if you're you students of corey
s pals uh
he uh helped me edit books that i've
written
and uh he's very funny guy and we
co-host the podcast and he also is
one of the co-producers he does the
pre-interviews finds people we
argue about discuss so you just show up
we should have recorded
that's what you're saying well
i mean yeah i guess that's the word
you're looking for bill
yeah yeah sure
and are you going on 20 years now as the
ceo of the planetary society
10 years now 10 years tempest fugit but
not quite
that well this is the organization
co-founded by carl sagan and and two
others so quite the mantle to be
ascending to there
yes well neil degrasse tyson was our
chairman of the board for a while no i
was never chair of the board i was on
the board i was never chairman you were
on the board
and then he drifted off wait did it feel
like i was cheering the board was i
making decisions i shouldn't have
no no it was fine but we missed you neil
because
i was just keeping meals on the board it
was fun
i i oh and now it's a chore no no
it's just it's different kind of fun so
in this first segment we're talking
about
baseball as a contact sport and normally
it is the last thing ever mentioned
when people give the list of contact
sports but of course as bill
is introducing here ball hits bat
pitcher
hits batter there's contact well the
other
the apparently the worst there's contact
the worst contact in
sports is the play at the plate where
one guy has almost no pads on
the other guy is trying to find the ball
while this other human is hurtling
toward him at 15 miles an hour or
whatever the heck
and if you play catcher people well if
you
play catch which i used to do yeah yeah
put your
be sure to have your left foot or
whatever it is your back foot
parallel to the third base line so when
the guy slides into your leg you fold at
the knee
and you don't bust up your knee yeah you
don't go sideways across your knees i
was bigger than all people sliding into
any details so i never
they fell backwards well back in the day
they used to call the uh
catcher's equipment the tools of
ignorance so they i'm pretty sure they
still do dj
right so let's start with let's start
organizationally here so bill
um if someone is throwing 100 mile an
hour fastball
because lately they've been clocking the
speed the exit speed
exit velocity of the ball or at least
the ball upon leaving the bat
and all the home runs seem to be 103
100 and 607 miles an hour is that all i
need
if i just make sure the ball leaves my
bat at that speed and at the right angle
am i basically getting a home run no
matter how big and bulky and strong i am
yeah but you just threw in offhandedly
oh and at the right angle
okay excuse me that's like a thing
so everybody in a pocket a
non-apocryphal story from the story of
neil and bill
one day neil's going musing blah blah
blah assuming a level swing
swap okay hold it
there's two different things in hitting
dj there's hitting and there's hitting
for power
yes so hitting you're aiming the ball
someplace trying to get it around
defenders over the defender's head
down the line so the defender has to run
towards you while you're running past
him and things like that
but then hitting for power you have to
hit it at an
angle that is going to take it up uh
over the fence yeah but
does that mean i don't have to be big
and burly to do that
no no that's the mystery of for example
from
my uh seattle fandom days ichiro suzuki
who went on to play
they all do went on to play for the
yankees
but this is a pretty small guy who could
hit home runs
yeah wait wait so dj
dj you're you're you're a burly guy
right you have girth and so when i think
of you holding a bat i think this guy's
powerful i should back
up but then like bill is saying you get
ichiro you get
altuve um you get people who are little
red sox had a few little people who hit
uh who's the guy with the red sox
that's who's now on the dodgers no but
also also the second baseman uh
dustin uh dustin pedroia okay these guys
can punch the ball
hit triples hit doubles i don't care if
there's a if there's a
green monster out there so so bill
is it just some kind of mythology
that you need to be big or do you just
have to move the bat
with precision and with speed
well that's all you have to do is move
it with precision and speed
yep thank you okay
in general big guys can wait guys who
are stronger
can wait a little longer to bring the
bat around
uh and direct the ball but if you're
strong you can
muscle the bat around later in the
pitch that's not muscle it's just speed
it's just reflex
well okay but the bat has mass and so
you're going to
overcome its inertia with strength
okay and i think is isaac newton who
said this
a lot of the little guys actually have i
mean some incredible bat speed
which which adds to that you know i mean
the altuve has got some incredible bat
speed and
you know with his size you you would
think that most balls probably would be
high to begin with
and you know because he's getting such
good you know good bat speed and a
little bit of angle upwards because
not to say that he's short but he is a
little shorter he
giving him the right ball he could
definitely send it a long way
so bill how about this great subtle
thing
at the point i make contact with the
ball how important is my musculature
if i don't think it's that important
it's the mass of the bat
it's the mass of the bat that's going to
so you're saying if i use a lighter
kinetic energy high speeds
well this is the great controversy so
furthermore
also in addition to continue what's
happening
is people are selecting thinner and
thinner bat
handles so that
the bat has a springiness if you were
somehow
allowed to play baseball with some
magical tennis racket
some racket that could handle
i guess that's a pun that could deal
with
accommodating more flex accommodate
you could really launch the ball uh much
much farther than is currently possible
um
compare and contrast jumping up and down
off a sidewalk
with jumping up and down off a
trampoline
so it's a bit like a hockey stick a bit
like a hook an ice hockey stick where
it's got that
it's composite but it's got that
flexibility in there is that the sort of
thing you're
talking about yeah so if you're allowed
to do that then so furthermore also
but you're saying the spring would give
it a little extra push
yeah yeah but so what happens then
another not for nothing effect is
people are wearing batting gloves and so
they have a thickness
the pads on the gloves have a thickness
so then people are selecting even
narrower bat handles
and um and uh
able to get more flex wait is this why
the bats are breaking because now
then you get bats breaking you look at
babe ruth's bat
from basketball tree trunk that's a
hickory
you know well it is it's so called
hickory strips
and uh you had to be quite strong to
bring that bad around
yeah they definitely met match the bats
to the player now too
you know what what do you mean by that
well i mean you know based on
size weight um you know the what the
what the the bat speed of the individual
is you can kind of gauge
what you what kind of bat they can
handle and before they break it
or the ball breaks it and how they can
get maximum amount of speed
they they cut the tops out to give it a
little bit less ounces more ounces
and
here's the problem with corking our
perception
might be cork is springy so if you put
springy material in the bat
[Music]
then you would get some that spring some
of that energy storing to the ball as it
left the bat
but it doesn't work because the ball is
in contact
for with the bat for such a short amount
of time
barely a thousandth of a second the
energy doesn't have time
to get into the cork and back out and
plus you lose
a tremendous amount at the interface
where the cork would touch the wood
so for people out there trying this it
doesn't work and i remembered the
corking
back in the 70s well it's been going on
since the 1800s
really okay okay then my in my my day
okay
one of the rationales was that you still
have the sort of the bulk of the bat but
you made it lighter
well you can drill all the freaking
holes in the bat you want
but then you weaken it and it will
shatter and
but then why why not just use a lighter
bat
so uh if you get it too light then it
fails it breaks
and uh uh this is the great you know
this is the magical thing about baseball
everybody that's what everybody loves
about it is
after a century and a half of dinking
around
things are just dialed in where it just
barely works it just barely doesn't work
and it's a game of thousands
of inches and it's just every pitch is a
statistic it's a game for nerds
so uh the thing about
the bats that makes me a little crazy
how about this rule dj if your bat
breaks you're out
how about that i i would break yourself
a pretty good rule i mean it'd be
interesting
but then everybody's like a parent bill
you broke down you gotta go and sit on
the naughty step well and you know
that's why we can't have nice things
so along this line um you know you
talked about altuve and also do the
aaron judge comparison
for them the strike down is in a
different place because one's five foot
five the other's six foot five seven
yeah seven
even um does altuve have an advantage
because
he can get his bat below as possible
ball that's coming in books have been
written as i like to remark
the answer is absolutely without
question
it depends good so
the reason both of these guys are having
success at the major league level
is they have compensated for the large
strike zone
by being a huge guy who can bring the
bat around really fast
and for having a small strike zone by
being a smaller guy who can bring the
bat around really fast
and so but it also sounds like bill that
if you're small
then um that shrinks the strike zone
so then the pitcher has to be more
accurate and you don't have to be able
to swing in more places than the big guy
except you can't reach as far as the big
guy
so the pitcher then has a has a bigger
strike zone
but it's a bigger one away and stuff
like that
yeah and you know we're as we say we're
getting into
where the the gray areas where it
depends
and i just want to go on and on about
these kids today
and the bats okay
so on a baseball bat is a label
a brand and skilled craftspeople in
kentucky making bats
put the brand so that the uh
grain is oriented to strike the ball
edge on and so back when i was a
seattleite
lived there for 26 years big mariner fan
big seahawks fan
i met with none other than chuck
armstrong who was
president not ceo not owner president of
the mariners organization to give a
little talk
to these kids these kids today about
branding a bat
so i had this very demonstration
so the grain of the bat is oriented that
way they put the label there
so that you strike the ball edge on
if you hit the ball this way the bat
will flex
and ultimately fail because the grains
will be moving
against each other they'll be sliding in
sheer as it's called
yeah so can i show that to some of my
college players
absolutely they don't know if tj
you made reference to parents getting
arms of kimbo about these kids breaking
their toys
uh if you're a parent
breaking bats is expensive you're gonna
have to go buy bats if you're
running a little league team or the next
level up
high school team and you're breaking
bats it's just like
it's too expensive so that's why they we
it went to aluminum bats now you can
engineer
an aluminum bat to have a tremendous
amount of flex
yeah and i played softball with a guy
who got hit in the face
with a ball that was just scream a third
baseman because just screaming because
there was a few years of sort of lack of
regulation in the springtivity
the springiness of the bats uh and so
but he got hit in the face with a ball
that was hit by
an aluminum battery a guy with an
aluminum battery playing softball wasn't
in the face with aluminum bat i just
wanted
not the best that would be very
troubling so anyway
uh that's why all the way through
college people play with aluminum bats
then if you're an
outstanding player and you get an
opportunity to play in the majors with a
wooden bat
you're not familiar with this notion of
branding the bat
and taking into account the mechanical
properties of the wood dj what do your
players use
um we use aluminum at that level um but
sure you know most of them use wood
during the summer um
you know just so that the you know
scouts and and coaches can get an
opportunity to see what they're capable
of doing with an actual bat
in a real situation yeah okay but even
at that level you're talking to me it's
dangerous
i mean it's super dangerous uh you know
i think i think all college balls should
go to wood
to be honest with you i mean why is it
dangerous
what's dangerous um the speed you can
get off the bat or the pitch
ball yeah you know so the the pitcher
has i mean think about it there are
pitchers in the major leagues that are
getting hit in the head
and and the ball is coming fractionally
slower than it would be in college when
they're using metal and they're all
prospects to that level so you you got a
guy that's
equivalent to an aaron judge that's six
six six seven that's 260
and he hits a ball with an aluminum bat
at a pitcher
that he's got no reaction time there's
no way that he's getting so bill back to
your original point
baseball has been has become
or has always been this game of
inches and microseconds and and so
the slightly better bat will kill the
pitcher
right well just that the pitcher stands
that close
has always been marvelous because when
you see them catch a ball that is back
to them it's like
oh my gosh any fraction of a second
faster or if they're slower the ball
faster they slower
they lose their head you got to wave at
it as they say yeah so
uh yeah anyway aluminum bats can be
tuned or engineered so that they don't
have this crazy springiness but then
they get
they get anesthetic they get heavy they
get heavy in the wrong way and so
this just gets into the whole wooden bat
controversy by the way
gary i don't know your background but
there's a guy in cricket called the
silly mid-off
yes it's a so it's a fielding position
yeah
it's also what are you doing you're
standing right in front of a guy with a
wooden club and a ball is going 100
miles an hour the clue's in the touch
no clue is quite simply their silly
position
yeah and so he doesn't wear gloves and
cricket they don't work they haven't
thought of that
we thought about it we just said no
no the only guy the wicket keeper is
allowed to do something that's right
and you must a bowler in cricket
can reach over a hundred miles an hour
because you are using the ground
as another part well we're getting we're
gonna get to that in the next segment
we're going to talk about the making of
a pitch
and i've had long conversations with
bill about this
and i still don't understand he's going
to have to throw in your legs
so when we come back star talk sports
edition the physics of baseball with
bill nye
we're back star talk sports edition the
physics
of baseball got gary reilly gary
hey neil yeah uh we lost chuck he's he's
on a gig
you tell me so that's good we'll check
check him out good for him check him out
on the next round
uh i've got with me uh my trainer i
guess former trainer because he moved to
florida dj price dj what's up
i have you on not because not because
you were my former trainer but because i
know you are
baseball crazy man and
every day all day every day you bleed
baseball
right so and just to have a ground truth
on this conversation we're having with
bill nye who's sharing with us
his sort of life's thinking and
expertise on
basically and bill you and i have had
conversations about what pitchers do
when they throw the ball right they're
not just throwing the ball
some other kinematic biophysiological
thing is going on
so could you just lay this out for us
what's going on on the mound
oh yeah sure i'm an expert on that now
everybody
uh gary yes you're a british descent
and so you grew up playing cricket kind
of yes
yeah well he's on here because he's a
former professional soccer player
that's craig i'm familiar with i have
held a bat and had things thrown at me
yeah so in cricket
not necessarily at the same time at the
same time
sorry no it's all good in cricket
they uh they you all allow the
bowler as he's called to
uh i presume there's some she boulders
two bowlers
to bounce the ball off the ground yeah
although you can you can bowl a full
toss so it
it gets to the wicket or the batsman
without
touching the ground but generally they
incorporate the ground and this
then adds another layer of physics to
the whole affair well here's the thing
that happened
i'm sure early on cricketers discovered
that the bowler could just
overwhelm the batter could just do
anything to the bad a bad or
batsman could not um
routinely handle the bold ball yeah
so they made a rule that the bowler has
to keep his elbows straight
okay oh to reduce the range of damage
they can commit
yeah okay let's do another okay fine but
what the bowler can do is run
use his legs and so there's an old
saying and dj
let me just see if this is a true fact
or what i whimsically call a false fact
that you throw with your legs i agree
so yeah so what do you want to do
what you want to do in the so to deal
with this
in u.s baseball originally us
and baseball they allowed you to push
off
a fixed object which is traditionally
called the pitching rubber
also in the rules is called the
pitcher's plate
you uh push with your back leg while you
throw
but you're allowed to bend your elbow so
it's the different rules
uh for throwing but in all of this
the key to it is how you grip the ball
or a key a very important aspect of it
rather is how you grip the ball
relative to the stitches or how you grip
the ball so
uh with respect to the stitches right so
uh this is the four seam where you see
all four seams
then you can hold it here and you see
two seams one
two one two
or you hold it a little crooked and you
get
um you get the curve ball
you get the slider and then people who
spend
hours and hours at this throw it with
hardly any spin on it
with the fork ball and then when
hardly any spin the stitches catch the
air
in spectacular ways and make it fly
funny wait what switch
between a fork ball and a and a
knuckle ball uh you can grip the fork
ball much more tightly
when you're trying to throw a knuckle
ball you can
you're barely hanging on and so you just
can't
throw it as you can't snap your wrist
with the same um
so that's a faster knuckle bolt right so
bill i'm much faster so they hold it all
these ways the whole goal
is for the batter to not hit the ball
right that's just the entire goal so you
want to fool the batter
right yes so you are using certain
aerodynamic principles
in your favor to help you fool the
batter because the battery's brain
sees it as just this this this object
coming towards them that might do normal
things that gravity would do to it but
you are now exploiting
what the air could do confusing my
newtonian
expectations for the ball is that a fair
characterization
sure i just dj how many times as a coach
have you mentioned
okay listen people we want to con fuse
our newtonian expectations all right i'm
going to use that today
i mean it's just it's an old baseball
expression you zoom me in for that one
because i want to see how that comes
down
to how everybody looks back at me so
what that's something so uh
this is these are pictures from one of
my favorite books
an album of fluid motion and you talk
about
fun anything that was on the bestseller
list recently i saw
yeah sure was uh anything that flows
so here is a sphere
and a fluid flu is going by it's a ball
in water
and you see these pulses
it's shedding vortices just like a
whistle
oh you can't whistle on zoom uh it's
shedding
pulses but if we affix a trip wire
this little wire then you see how much
more smooth
the flow downstream is a tripwire to to
make texture to the surface
yeah and what it does the way i describe
it
is it causes molecules to tumble
and when they tumble they shear they
they go past each other this way
and their uh interaction
changes and they flow more smoothly
so then in the ultimate amazing
altitivity of great amazingness
where is it here we go we put a baseball
in a wind tunnel with streams of smoke
and you see where the stitches the
stitch has
tripped the boundary layer it sticks to
the ball much more smoothly where the
stitch is downstream of the boundary
layer of the
of the free stream it causes the tumble
so this interaction of smoothness versus
tumbling
causes changes in pressure on each side
of the ball
and it flies funny and it's hard to hit
and pitchers and bowlers exploit this
they go crazy for this
okay we have to assume that the
inventors of baseball didn't have
fluid dynamics in mind at the time they
just tried to stitch a freaking ball
together
they discovered oh but they discovered
the properties of this like that
right so players but what if neil yeah
and i think we've had
uh meredith wills who's a physicist
herself
yes did a little bit of an investigation
and the thread they used
in the stitches was uh something like 10
or so percent
thicker yeah she was she was accounting
for the higher
baseball the higher home run that's
right great
yes so bill what what's up with that
yeah
so different leagues are allowed to use
different
stitches in general the younger the
players are
the higher the stitches the more raised
they are
yeah i mean just maybe that's absolutely
true the younger the players the higher
the stitches the thicker the thread
which uh enables the pitchers to learn
to use
to exploit this more readily then in the
major league the stitches get quite
thin and this demands more of the
pitcher he has to have
more skill and when i've hung out with
these guys and dj you must know more
they just walk around the clubhouse all
day
snapping their fingers to get the
strength
so they can um you know and just and
testing to see how the ball moves when
they do it too
so you know they can get different
angles and and uh
you know the they're trying new things
all the time putting pressure on one
finger it'll give you one effect putting
pressure on another finger will give you
another
a completely opposite effect just like
that but you're also talking about
length of fingers
you know like like marion rivera for
example had one finger that was longer
a yankee by the way yeah he's a yankee
and he
and he he picked that up because one day
um
one of his coaches was telling him just
to you know throw it with a little bit
more pressure on
another finger and he was getting he
wasn't getting as much run and then he
told him just throw it the way you want
you normally throw it and then all of a
sudden his ball started running because
he wasn't putting
the pressure on the finger that was
longer and he was just using it and it
was staying on the ball longer and then
creates the best pitch in baseball to
cut fastball wait wait wait what do you
mean
he had a long finger what what what like
his finger was
abnormally longer than most wait so you
sound like he only has one finger
so please which finger are you talking
about the fingers he puts on the ball so
he had two fingers on the ball
is he my his one finger of his middle
finger may have been a little bit longer
than most pitchers which so he gets to
stay in contact with the ball as it
rolls out of his hand longer
and therefore give it a little extra
push right and he gets
uh and that's where he got his cut
fastball from and
it was just by accident just tj tell us
about the cut fastball yeah
yeah so that's a fastball right and
that's a cut
fastball is that right um you just move
it over a little bit
it's a it can be anywhere that's the
thing
it's relative to where like where you
have release on the ball and pressure on
the fault so what we're doing is
fastball is always over the top
right there's no you're not trying to go
to one side or the other side
you're trying to get over the top but
usually the fingers are close together
all right and some guys throw it right
down the middle where they have the
the small end of the the horseshoe some
guys put a little bit more curve on the
on the outside
yeah some guys turn it so that it's um
yeah that's it exactly and they're just
all they're doing is throwing it
throwing it just like a fastball but the
ball would come
off a little bit left or right
and it does so dj is am i right in
saying that that is considered
possibly probably the most difficult
thing
or skill to execute in the world of
sport
based on mariano rivera i would totally
agree
because he was he was he had so let's
see what they call the cutter that's
what they call yes the cutter he had
two pitches he had two pitches he had a
cutter
and a fastball and you it was hard to
dictate which one was coming because his
release point was identical
so we always let go of the ball at a
certain place so that's where hitters
are trying to get a little bit of
an idea of where the ball is coming out
based on release point angles of the
hand
what part of the hand you see he always
let go of his fastball like this
so he came over the top and off but it
depend on which
pressure he had given more to that
finger and then the ball would
you're not going to read that from the
plate are you no you don't read it until
it's too late and that's why he broke
a massive amount of bats i mean like you
would watch him and he would be breaking
bats left and right because
you're seeing fastball in your brain
and normally with breaking pitches and
change-ups and slower pitches there's
like
a light that goes off this emergency hey
that's not the same
stay back right so then you you you know
you fight it off you do something
different but when his fastball was
literally a mile per hour
slower or i mean his cup basketball was
a mile per hour slower
you're registering that too late and all
of a sudden
it's it goes from the middle of the
plate to your knuckles and you are now
like
all right if i don't get my hands in now
i'm going to get hurt
not not even just like am i going to
make contact i'm my life is in danger i
have to do something to stop it from
happening
and you know guys were taking like crazy
swings because they were just trying to
fight it off i mean guys were going
through bats two three bats in a bat
you know because of that fastball and
that's what made him so devastating
because the ball was going
it was an identical pitch it was
identical release point
but the last second is where you get
that little
cut that little break and it's hard to
register if they're coming at the same
speed
well wait bill bill how how can the ball
do something
different part way through the arc that
it's taking
how's that even possible well so
uh the wall doesn't just stop i mean it
was a bugs bunny
where all-time
like the slow ball and the ball just
kind of wiggles and
and jiggles and stops and continues
so that's of course a cartoon extreme of
this but
um is is dj describing
something an impression of what the ball
is doing rather than what the ball is
actually doing
so uh to give credit where credit is due
robert adair are the physics of baseball
physicists to the major leagues uh
talked about this being the same
phenomenon
observed by two different people so your
point of view is what's producing this
so
as the ball is coming toward the plate
not only is it
as soon as you let go of it it's slowing
down because of air
the air is slowing it down but it's also
falling and so if you can get it to slow
down and fall
in a different way by changing how fast
it's going when it leaves your hand
and changing where you aim it it appears
to the batter to be moving across the
plate
but it's moving across yeah yeah sorry
yeah
well said uh and so it's always doing
that it's just changing the rate at
which it's doing that
and you guys when you start getting in
the most difficult thing ever in sports
i mean i
i don't know i watch hockey players do
what baseball players do
backwards and on ice skates so i'm
open-minded
no except wait wait bill most of the
time the puck is on the ice
so that reduces one of the degrees of
freedom of how and where you find it
before you hit it most of the time
dimensions uh neil it's the most of the
time
that makes it really difficult okay no
modern players modern hockey players
lift the park yeah
they lift the puck yeah they totally
look like you're hitting a spherical
object with a round
bat so as the saying goes and you're
you're a soccer player the ball is round
mm-hmm
a larger surface area a flatter area
whether it's the side of my foot
either outside or inside or the instep
yeah which is a
larger surface area to make contact with
the ball but isn't it an old saying
that the ball is round anything can
happen
well let me get to that just before we
take a break bill give me like your most
succinct
comment on the pres on
what fraction of an in what a fraction
of an inch
difference contact with the ball makes
for well for the fate of the ball after
it leaves the bat
it's on the order of a few sheets of
paper really
yeah five or six thousands of an inch
yeah
so you know you can if you're a human
and a lot of your uh
viewers are um yeah
you can you can feel the difference
between two thousands and four
thousands without much difficulty but
that much difference
uh will make a tremendous difference in
the flight so it's an exaggeration to
even say
a fraction of an inch it's even like a
tiny tiny tiny fraction of an inch yeah
yeah
this is the charm but think about this
people just something else
but that means the big sluggers the
successful home run hitters
can can decide in a fraction a little
fraction of a second
whether they're going to swing swing a
round
stick make contact with a round ball
and hit the ball 450 feet
that's i've seen it yeah yes but don't
forget neil you're adding history
of their one-to-one confrontations into
the mix not just
what's this guy dialing up in this
moment what has this guy dialed up to me
in the past at certain
certain moments in the match in a game
so there's a whole lot i mean dj
a lot of educated guessing um you know
so
it does come down to they have books on
everybody you know like
usually rookies have a a good go first
couple times through because they
they don't know doesn't know what the
ball looks like when it comes off you
know when you start getting used to
seeing somebody throw a ball
and that's why nowadays most starters
don't make it through three rounds of
of nine so they they usually only go two
two and a half because
by that time that third time i've seen
him i know what his pitch is i know
where he's throwing me i know what he's
trying i know his plan
so you know like the good pitchers
nowadays don't make it nine innings
because of the fact that the hitters are
actually
they're so much more um you know math
and they're coming in there trust me i'm
not
i'm not trying i'm an athlete as well
but uh they're not coming in going i got
it
and it's the fact that there are people
down there actually giving them
information like books of it like hey
you just
you know last time he got you out on
this watch for this first pitch
okay now i have i'm looking curveball
first pitch
i know curveball's coming if it's in my
hitting zone i'm going to take the best
swing possible and see how hard i can
hit this thing
you know and that that's that's where
you preload the precision of what you're
doing
and of course they say even great home
run hitters strike out more often than
they hit a home run
so right because of the bad angle that
they're taking but that's besides the
point i think a lot of the guys
are are striking out now because of the
bad angles and how they're changing it
um they're they're they're two their
degrees of upward swing is changing how
consistent people are hitting the ball
um so i
and i don't i don't know why it doesn't
make any sense i mean back when
when i was growing up in the 80s and 90s
it was
you know 300 was the was it you wanted
to bat 300. now you got guys there in
the lineups batting 217
with 40 home runs and they're all right
well he's he's a home run and every kid
wants to be him but
what about the guy that's that in 340
like a dj le mayhew
you know that he hits the ball over the
place but then he hits a little dribble
up the middle scores two runs and
everybody's like
well he could have hit it out you know
but he didn't
you know like that that's not baseball i
mean a high average is
is a player when we come back more star
talk sports edition
the physics of baseball with bill nye
we're back star tall sports edition the
physics of baseball
got my longtime friend bill nye who
thinks if you didn't know this
this man thinks and breathes baseball
uh he's he's a student of baseball as
you might say
and i also brought in someone from the
trenches dj price a former trainer of
mine who moved to florida
to coach baseball in fact he coached
while he was here in new york
and so he knows some insides and outs
and
each of you are here to keep each other
honest about what you say about the
sport
but i want to take this segment and
start thinking about
um the air
the texture of the air the humidity in
the air the
air pressure and how do these other
factors these climatic factors
influence either the pitch the hit the
fielders
and so bill what can you tell me about
so humidity in baseball
well uh consider the following uh air is
mostly nitrogen
and nitrogen is what everyone diatomic
exactly so it has nitrogen travels
i concur
nitrogen travels around with two
nitrogen molecules hooked together and
two
and you got it so by i guess
two in greek is dye so diatomic
uh deuce uh it missed latin deuce deo
that was
two all right okay now so what on a
humid day
some water molecules are nudging aside
some nitrogen molecules well they're
nudging aside some argon and xenon and
all these other happy molecules
but or atoms in some cases but um
air ma water molecules are less massive
than nitrogen molecules
and most of air is nitrogen 70
or so so when a ball is going through
the air that's humid
it's pushing aside atoms that are less
massive
it has to it can travel faster and
farther through
a humid air day than a cold
dry day and this is
so not trivial
this is so noticeable in baseball
especially in cricket
especially where you're hitting the ball
and it's flying at
100 miles an hour pushing aside air
molecules if they're less massive it
goes farther
and so and now that seems like if we
follow this line of reasoning
that if you go to a mile high stadium
where there's just
simply less air because air pressure is
lower
that doubles down on this effect
presumably yeah
it's a true fact not a false fact as i
whimsically remark
so you should be able to plot home runs
per altitude of stadium and it should go
up
so cool in denver right yeah the home of
the rockies
they i think else beginning of the 21st
century
introduced a humidor the sort of thing
you have for your cigars
yes no all my cigars are in a humidor
there you go so
that then because of the yarn inside the
ball it allows
the yarn to absorb a little more
moisture and therefore
kind of damps it down is that is that
the thinking there
wait what you're saying they put the
ball in a humidor not the stadium in a
humidor
correct right that's a rather large
humidor okay so so bill
right the humidity effects gets into
everything so i
if i have a crisp ball moving through
humid air i get it
but if my ball is kind of mushy because
it sat in a humid environment
then what so the ball doesn't go off the
bat as strongly as fast
the uh the height okay so this so it's a
mitigating
it's a it's a mitigating factor on the
humidity that would otherwise make it go
farther
yeah yeah so when the rockies first
started playing it was just home run
home run home run yeah
long hit long hit long hit but they had
this innovation they
they get the balls humid and it uh
slows them down a little bit why is that
why do they want to do that
everybody likes home runs uh well the
the game became uh complicated in that
you all the strategy all the tactics
that a pitcher
where infielders would stand the
batter's approach to the ball everything
was changed
by the ball traveling so much farther
swinging it about as hard
also the pitchers had much more
difficulty
causing the ball to curve or change but
then they could throw it faster
so these two things so the thing about
baseball that everybody's kooky for
is every pitch is the statistic
every pitch is a datum in the great
pantheon of baseball record keeping
i don't know if that's a pantheon the
great record books of record keeping and
so they made adjustments
annals they made adjustments to make the
statistics
more meaningful when you're playing in
denver
and you know people when when you play
baseball
otherwise it's just a free-for-all well
the word free-for-all it changes the to
statistics for the home team it changes
the statistics
statistics for the visiting team well
the yankees had all these great
left-handed sluggers and they made the
right
field fence 296 feet so
so how many babe ruth home runs dropped
in at 298 feet
on the right field line dj do you guys
actively
know that humid air the ball goes
farther when you hit it
is that an actively known thing it's not
something that um that i'm thinking
from a scientific perspective but i'd
rather hit a baseball
in june and july than in september and
october
that much i do know oh okay so somehow
it's in the psychology of what you would
okay i always say baseball players are
probably
the smartest physicists that don't know
it
because we're always thinking about
stuff like that but we don't know what
we're thinking about from a scientific
perspective
because for sure you know humid air is
heavy
and then you think and but bill nye just
explained that away
right yeah it's not a matter of it it's
a different when you when you hit a ball
in october
and september late september in the
north uh
it's uncomfortable and you know it
doesn't feel the same way in july and
most of the places you go to in july and
june it's
pretty hot so you know like i used
reggie jackson mr october was such a
significant
it was more than just it's it's world
series season it's
october yeah
the air is is cold and crisp and
and all that goes with the audio it's a
different game i mean and even like you
know looking from a west coast east
coast kind of thing you know
the even down south in florida i mean uh
we would come down here
for for spring training when from new
york and it was like
oh wow you just feel it the ball's gonna
go further it's gonna you're gonna throw
it a little harder you're gonna run a
little faster i feel it so you're
the you're the the um
the the uh the unsuspecting physicist
just like you said that's great i love
that
so so gary offline you were telling us
you had a question about
about uh global warming effect yes why
did you hand that to
bill okay bill so we've we've seen
record temperatures in death valley this
year something like 130 plus but i think
we should build a stadium in death
valley
which is very very high air pressure
because it's very it's very low
elevation
and then curve balls would be amazing
yeah there might be a problem in the
field
also you know the game depends not this
year but
generally on fans coming to the stadium
and if it's 105 degrees that's another
drawback i get that but holding aside
those complications that would be a good
ball thrower's dream
a stable ball player from 29 palms 29
guys so uh yeah as the world gets warmer
the air
gets warmer and less dense and we will
expect the ball to go farther so places
like your beloved seattle
well wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait two-things wait what can
we just say two things hold on hold on
bill just said one thing that even means
two things right
so bill as the world gets warmer uh
warmer air is thinner
right there's fewer molecules per cubic
meter or whatever okay
a and b if the world gets warmer we are
evaporating more
moisture and keeping more moisture in
the air
so it's more human is it true that the
air on
in general would be more humid yeah i
mean
that's my certainly first cut at it
that's what i would expect
yeah okay so we have two reasons why
balls would would go out in in a in a
in a global warmed earth
baseball will have more home runs yeah
yeah and more extra bass hits and
also uh higher pitch speeds
and the faster the pitcher throws it and
you make contact
the farther would the ball would go if
there's saying let the pitcher do the
work
many of us have seen sort of strobe
photos of a golf ball getting hit and
you see the golf ball
collapsing and then recoiling do you
know how much a baseball
i remember when i was a kid and i
unraveled a baseball it was i
it was it was one of the happiest
moments of my life i think
wow i just discovered that there's like
rubber inside and then there's a little
there's like a candy thing in the center
you know it was just this
like with tootsie roll pop right exactly
i felt like i was the first person
discovering this um and uh
do you know how much a baseball deforms
so the ball
compresses a surprising amount like
imagine if you could grip a baseball and
squeeze it with your
index finger and middle finger so that
your
index and middle finger were uh fully
submerged
in the surface of the ball that's about
how much it compresses
it's really uh surprising mm-hmm um the
ball
restoring to its shape so the ball is
in is in a way propelling itself
in the aftermath of that collapse well
when you jump off a trampoline is
is the trampoline propelling you or is
it you well it's the answer is both
you're storing energy in the balls or
the springs of the trampoline so
how long does it take what sort of
timeline are we looking at here from
impact deformation and then returning to
its original shape
about a thousandth of a second that long
they're
you know not a hundredth much less i
mean way less than that
uh if we're 100th of a second gary i
think you would see that
in their high-speed replays
a thousandth of a second it's not
catching that yeah and it has to return
quite quickly because it won't fly
obviously as well
right the act of returning off the
surface of the bat it gives it
propels it forward like like bill said
it's the impulse which is a physics term
i think that they've shown some pictures
of that like of of contact where the
ball gets deformed and almost
you know envelopes itself over the bat
it's it's wild
yeah that's really surprising what sort
of velocities are we talking about dj
for a bat
if if if we've got a real power hitter
what sort of speed
is this bat meeting the ball well let me
ask that another way
if the ball leaves the bat at 105 miles
an hour does that mean i hit the ball at
105 miles an hour
is my bat moving at 105 can the ball go
faster than the speed with which i swung
the bat
that's that's that's a question for bill
i really don't know yeah yeah so you
know this from a famous
wonderful science teacher demonstration
you get a basketball
and a tennis ball and
uh oh the double bump the double butt
can yes so go ahead neil describe it to
the listener man no but you started it
but i'd i would i would so delight in
describing this okay so if and we have
we've actually had to calculate this in
physics class because it's
the result is unbelievable you see it
and you say i don't believe it and then
you calculate it
and then the calculation shows that's
what must happen if you take a large
ball and a small ball on top of it
okay so the large ball has to be much
bigger than the small boat so it could
be a bad
basketball and like a marble or
well a marble is pretty good but you can
use a a baseball or you can use
our baseball that's fine a tennis ball
is the traditional thing something much
bigger than that ball so take a
basketball
and a bit and a baseball sure so
drop one by itself it'll come up to a
certain height drop the other
by itself it'll come up to a certain
height take the smaller ball
hold it just above the big ball
and drop them simultaneously the other
traditional thing is a little strip of
double stick tape or a loop
a loop of tape so that the ball is as
you drop it it stays kind of stays
uh right so there you go as they drop
what happens is
the bottom ball hits first
recoils off the ground goes upward
and hits the small ball which is itself
coming
in and then doubling back off of its own
recoil as well as the basketball as we
call and it goes up
nine times as high yeah so
wow the traditional thing is a
basketball and tennis ball
and so the basketball is so much more
massive
than the tennis ball when its momentum
is transferred to the tennis ball
it becomes it changes into this or red
it is uh manifested as a high change in
speed
of the tennis ball and it's basically
launched it goes it's cool it goes
50 feet in the air i mean it's a
striking
experiment that you do unintended in in
beginning physics
okay so i like that well the baseball
you guys is all
so-called classical physics there's no
that's what i said in physics and you
got all me mad at me
i didn't really get mad i just if you're
a baseball coach
i don't know how much people respond i'm
using all the fluids
all right guys we got to land this plane
thank you bill nye
do you still go by science guy or is
that an occasion yeah yes yes it's
trademarked people don't make me come
over here
[Laughter]
thank you gary dj neal thanks for having
me thank you
gary always good to have you co-host
pleasure dj was good it's great to have
you back on this yeah man it's good
seeing you again
i hope you enjoy florida yeah crazy
people
stay well dj playing a lot of golf it's
very enjoyable here
you got it all right i'm neil degrasse
tyson your personal
astrophysicist as always bidding you to
keep
you